the heart of the geforce gaming platform
is our family of gpus
and the 60 class is our most popular
the affordable price point is designed
to bring the performance and features of
our latest architecture
to every gamer for example the gtx 1060
was one of our most successful gpus we
ever built
the gtx 1060 delivered a great
generational leap in performance
it could power all the latest games at
1080p
60 frames per second but new games bring
bigger worlds and cinematic graphics
that demand more of the gpu
this is evident in the latest sequels to
these aaa games
where the gtx 1060 struggles to keep up
for instance gamers were playing
watchdogs 2 with high settings
at 60 frames per second but with
watchdogs legion released last october
they only get 24 frames per second
and an even bigger change is underway
turn on ray tracing
and these games become unplayable on the
1060.
with 90 percent of the installed base on
gtx
now is the perfect time to deliver an
rtx for every gamer
let me introduce the new geforce rtx
3060
which brings the power of ampere our
second generation rtx architecture
to every gamer twice the raster
performance of the 1060
and 10 times the ray tracing performance
the rtx 3060 powers the latest games
with rtx on at 60 frames per second
[Music]
the rtx 3060 is a powerful gpu
it has 13 shader teraflops 25
rt teraflops for ray tracing and 101
tensor teraflops to power dlss
it has 12 gigabytes of g6 memory and
starts at just 3
29 the rtx 3060 will be available
worldwide
in late february amazing gaming doesn't
end at the desktop
laptops are the fastest growing gaming
platform increasing
seven times in seven years there are 50
million gaming laptops
which powered over 14 billion gaming
hours last year
and the power of these laptops has
inspired gamers to find new ways to play
in console mode connected to a big
screen tv using a controller
or driving an ultra wide monitor with a
keyboard and mouse
these high performance machines also
meet the needs of 45 million creators
and everyone working and studying from
home
today we are announcing a new generation
of ampere-powered laptops
with second generation rtx and
third-generation max-q technologies
delivering twice the power efficiency of
previous generations
nowhere does efficiency matter more than
in the extremely
power constrained environment of a
modern gaming laptop
so four years ago we introduced maxq
maxq is a system design approach that
delivers high performance
in thin and light gaming laptops it has
fundamentally changed how laptops are
built
every aspect the cpu gpu software pcb
design
power delivery thermals are optimized
for power
and performance our third generation
max-q
technologies use ai and new system
optimizations
to make high-performance gaming laptops
faster and better than ever
traditionally gaming laptops set the
power for the cpu and gpu
yet games and creative apps are dynamic
and demands on the system change from
frame to frame
today we are introducing dynamic boost
2.0
which for the first time uses ai to
shift power between the cpu
gpu and now gpu memory determining where
it is needed most
the ai networks in dynamic boost 2.0
manage power on a per frame basis
so your laptop is constantly optimizing
for maximum performance
the result is a larger performance boost
than ever before
we are also introducing whisper mode 2.0
delivering a new level of acoustic
control for gaming laptops
whisper mode has been re-engineered from
the ground up
and is custom built into each laptop at
a system level
you pick your desired acoustics and
whisper mode 2.0
ai powered algorithms manage the cpu
gpu system temperature and fan speeds
to deliver great acoustics at the best
possible performance
next we are introducing resizable bar
which leverages the advanced
capabilities of pci express
to boost gaming performance games use
gpu memory for textures
shaders and geometry constantly updating
as the player moves through the world
today only part of the gpu's memory can
be accessed at any one time by the cpu
requiring many memory updates
with resizable bar the game can access
the entire gpu memory
allowing for multiple updates at the
same time
improving performance finally dlss is a
breakthrough for gaming laptops
it uses ai and rtx tensor cores to
deliver
up to 2x the performance in the same
power
a gpu needs to calculate almost 4
million pixels
for a single 1440p frame dlss requires
only a fraction of the pixels
which improves efficiency and increases
performance
it also delivers more battery life when
you are gaming on the go
maxq has reinvented the gaming laptop
four years ago the fastest laptops in
the world were powered by a gtx 1080
averaged 40 millimeters thick and
weighed over nine pounds
after four years of innovation max-q gen
3
laptops are half the size half the
weight and deliver up to 10 times the
performance
more gamers are choosing to play on
laptops and with 95
of the installed base below the
performance of the latest consoles
it's time to introduce a new generation
the rtx 3060 laptop is faster than
anything on the market today including
the 2500
rtx 2080 super it's 30
faster than the playstation 5 and
delivers 90 frames per second on the
latest games
at ultra settings 1080p the rtx 3060
laptops start
at just 9.99 gamers know that 1440p
displays
with twice the pixels of 1080p provide
the perfect mix of high fidelity
graphics and great performance
yet they are missing on laptops for
years we've been working behind the
scenes with display manufacturers and
oems
now for the first time 1440p displays
will be widely available
introducing the geforce rtx 3070 laptop
a 1440p gaming beast it's 50
faster than the rtx 2070 and delivers 90
frames per second
with ultra settings at 1440p rtx 3070
laptops start at 12.99
finally our flagship geforce rtx 3080
laptop
with up to 16 gigabytes of g6 memory
it is a world's fastest laptop for
gamers and creators
it delivers a hundred frames per second
with rtx on
and starts at 19.99
today nearly three quarters of laptop
gamers play esports
the resulting popularity of high refresh
rate laptops continues to grow
doubling this past year i'm excited to
announce that over
half of the new 30 series laptops will
offer 240 hertz
or higher refresh rates with the
performance of our geforce rtx 3080
laptop gpu
gamers will be able to play at 240
frames per second
across top titles like overwatch rainbow
six
ballarant and fortnite and combined with
nvidia reflex
gamers can achieve sub 20 millisecond
system latency
enabling them to play their absolute
best
from videos to photography to 3d
animation
the creation of digital content is
exploding
nvidia studio is our accelerated
platform for creators
speeding up ray tracing and ai in over
50 applications
including adobe photoshop davinci
resolve and blender
and monthly studio drivers bring new
features
faster performance and enhanced
stability since the launch of studio in
2019
there have been over a hundred
purpose-built studio laptops and
desktops
from every major oem nvidia ampere
architecture takes studio laptops to the
next level
rendering is up to five times faster
than pascal
video editors can work with ak raw
footage
use ai to simplify workflows and reduce
encode times by up to 75
artists have up to 16 gigabytes of
graphics memory to work with huge assets
across multiple apps at the same time
rtx accelerated ai will change the way
creators work for example adobe
photoshop
recently introduced neural filters which
uses ai
to quickly make complex edits to
photographs
adobe premiere pro auto reframe uses ai
to convert landscape video to portrait
while keeping the action front and
center
in davinci resolve 17 the new magic mask
feature
uses ai to speed up mask creation
and tracking nvidia optics ai de noising
in blender
cleans up noise on the fly quickly
resolving 3d images
nvidia omniverse audio to face uses ai
to animate unrigged 3d characters based
solely on an audio source a new nation
conceived in liberty and dedicated to
the proposition
that all men are created equal
today we're introducing over 70 laptops
from
every oem our biggest launch ever
these are the world's fastest laptops
that give gamers
and creators a huge variety to pick the
right device for their needs
available beginning january 26 with
prices starting at 9.99
let's take a look at what they can do
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
rtx is the new standard and the momentum
continues to grow
with most of the installed base
underpowered for the latest games
we're bringing rtx to every gamer with
the geforce
rtx 3060. finally as more gamers are
choosing laptops
we're launching a new generation of rtx
laptops
ready to play the most demanding games
thanks everyone for tuning in today and
as always thanks to all of our fans for
all their support
and before we go we've got one more
treat for you
[Music]
for takeoff
[Music]
europe three thousand one hundred feet
[Music]
contact
[Music]
[Music]
sierra turn next tax away
you